vous êtes arrivés nous allons pouvoir
commencer
monsieur Bacher est bien debout
bien madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires européennes chez
des affaires économiques
ah je sais pas si tu conduisas mais en
tout cas tu peux être président de deux
en même temps
chers Sophie prima mes chers collègues
le projet européen est ambitieux par
nature le seul objectif de construire à
27 un marché intérieur qui plus est
largement adossé à une monnaie unique
étant lui-même un défi immense dont la
réalisation qui est loin d'être achevée
implique une convergence dans un nombre
croissant de domaines débordant
largement le seul champ économique et
monétaire et fragilisé actuellement par
les chocs économiques qui frappent ce
marché de manière symétrique et
asymétrique c'est un chemin
au long cours qui est semé d'embûches
nous le constatons actuellement à cet
égard la guerre en Ukraine est bien plus
qu'une embûche c'est un séisme
géopolitique qui ébranle tous les défis
européens ce séisme a aussi des
répercussions économiques les sanctions
européennes contre l'agresseur russe
alimentent la flambée des prix de
l'énergie qui elle-même provoque une
poussée inflationniste dans toute
l'Union européenne euro stade de la
récemment évoluer après de 10% auto
annuel notre pays étant l'un des moins
touchés avec
6,2%. l'Union européenne qui avait
l'ambition de rebondir après le choc
conjoncturel de la pandémie et qui
affiche aussi des ambitions de plus long
terme coupant les nécessaires
transitions vertes et numérique voit ses
efforts contrarié par ce nouveau concept
elle lutte aujourd'hui pour éviter les
fermetures d'entreprises étrangler par
leur facture énergétique or
parallèlement l'Union européenne se voit
conduite par la pandémie et par la
guerre à élargir encore le champ de ses
ambitions elle assume désormais vouloir
construire son autonomie stratégique
pour défendre ses intérêts et soutenir
ses valeurs au plan international et
elle entend décliner cette autonomie au
niveau militaire industrielle
pharmaceutiques alimentaires et spatial
nous nous situons donc dans un contexte
européen paradoxal avec d'un côté des
ambitions qui sont toujours plus
grandissantes et de l'autre des chocs
économiques qui s'accumulent je relève
d'ailleurs que ce paradoxe n'a pas
empêché le commissaire européen France
Timmerman d'annoncer encore hier à la
cop27 un renforcement des ambitions
climatiques de l'Union alors même que le
coût économique et social du pacte vert
sur lequel le Sénat n'a pas manqué
d'alerter commence enfin à faire des
bains
c'est cette tension entre ambition
européenne et choc économique qui nous a
conduit à organiser cette table ronde
avec des économistes nous accueillons
donc Jean Pisani ferry qui enseigne à
Paris Berlin et Florence et qui a fondé
Bruegel 5 tank économique européen qui
vient d'être missionné par le
gouvernement pour évaluer les impacts
macroéconomiques de la transition
écologique nous recevons aussi Xavier
Timbaud directeur principal de
l'Observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques qui enseignent aussi à
Sciences Po et qui a notamment travaillé
sur l'inflation la croissance et le
pacte de stabilité européen enfin nous
accueillons à distance Charles whiplose
enseignant à Genève et économiste
spécialiste de l'intégration européenne
qui a d'ailleurs publié en 2005 avec
Jean Pisani Ferri un livre dont le titre
résonne encore aujourd'hui l'Europe
déclassée est-ce que vous nous entendez
bien en visio
je vous remercie donc de votre présence
aujourd'hui votre parole qui est experte
messieurs nous sera précieuse pour
envisager dans quelle mesure et à quel
prix les ambitions de l'Union pourraient
devenir réalité il est en effet
nécessaire d'évaluer les effets des
chocs conjoncturels sur l'économie
européenne et bien sûr et avant tout sur
nos concitoyens
il est tout aussi nécessaire d'évaluer
les conséquences des réponses qui sont
apportées en urgence pour amortir ses
effets conséquence immédiate et
conséquences à moyen et à long terme en
particulier au regard des objectifs de
l'Union européenne inflation galopante
oses vertigineuse des prix de l'énergie
difficultés d'approvisionnement matière
première critique fragilité des chaînes
d'approvisionnement les conséquences de
ces chocs sur le marché intérieur
apparaissent chaque jour plus violente
jusqu'où l'inflation peut-elle aller les
mesures budgétaires prises pour la
compenser sont-elles appropriées dès
lors qu'elles empêchent le signal prix
de jouer
ces mesures sont-elles suffisantes
sont-elles prises à juste échelon dès
lors que ce choc inflationniste qui
frappe l'ensemble des 27 sont apportées
des ont apporté des réponses
asymétriques et que cette disparité des
plans nationaux corrélés à l'état des
finances publiques dans les États
membres et alors mix énergétique risque
d'entraîner des distorsions de
concurrence à l'intérieur du marché
unique la combinaison entre ces mesures
et leur mode de financement sont-ils
pertinents et efficaces dans l'immédiat
et à moyen terme je pense notamment à la
création des ressources propres
et préconisez-vous d'autres initiatives
au niveau européen pour amortir les
conséquences de ces chocs à l'instar de
l'emprunt mutualisé levé pour financer
le plan de relance européen après
l'impôt la pandémie quant aux mesures
monétaire prises pour juguler
l'inflation sont-elles pertinentes ne
risque-t-elle pas de casser durablement
la croissance les prévisions disponibles
sont à cet égard très préoccupantes plus
généralement dans quelle mesure la
réponse apportée au choc économique que
subit actuellement l'Union européenne
est-elle de nature à réduire ses
capacités à atteindre les objectifs
ambitieux qu'elle s'est fixée dont on a
entendu qu'elle souhaitait les accroître
dès lors faudrait-il réviser certains de
ses objectifs en termes d'exigence deux
calendriers voire quelques fois de
pertinence dans un environnement
économique et géopolitique mondial
chaque jour plus incertain messieurs les
économistes voici les questions qui nous
préoccupent tout particulièrement mais
avant de vous entendre je sais bien sûr
la parole à Sophie prima
dont on connaît l'importance de la
nazisme objective au niveau de la
commission des affaires économiques nous
travaillons très transversalement entre
nos deux commissions parce que justement
le lien est étroit
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues messieurs je vais être je vais
essayer d'être rapide je voudrais
ajouter à la présentation complète qui
vient d'être faite par le président
arabe que c'est un grand honneur pour
nous de vous accueillir tous les trois
cette trois économistes prestigieux
c'est une chance pour nous de vous
écouter en ce début d'après-midi car si
le savant et le politique ont des rôles
bien distincts dans la société je crois
que nous autres les hommes et les femmes
politiques gagnant toujours à vous
écouter et à analyser ce que vous avez
et la vision que vous avez du monde cela
nous permet d'ailleurs parfois de sortir
par le haut de posture parfois trop
idéologique dans lesquelles on pourrait
être tenté de s'enfermer donc merci
vraiment d'être là cette table ronde ce
matin elle s'intitule ambition
européenne et choc économique vos
profils sont complémentaires et ils vont
nous permettre de naviguer conjoncture
et long terme le président a été assez
complet j'ai juste peut-être une ou deux
questions complémentaires la première
elle est assez simple sommes-nous en
train de sacrifier nos ambitions
européennes de long terme à la gestion
des chocs économiques de court terme les
dépenses d'aujourd'hui sont autant de
dépenses qui auraient pu être consacré à
la transition climatique le grand défi
de 2050 monsieur Pisani ferry vous venez
de publier une note très
perturbante en tout cas qui s'intitule
l'action climatique un enjeu
macroéconomique dans laquelle vous
rappelez une évidence qui fait consensus
je crois parmi les économistes les
efforts de sobriété et les
investissements dans la décarbonation
vont affecter la croissance l'inflation
les finances publiques la compétitivité
l'emploi nous vous lisons monsieur les
amis ferry et ces incitants sont
aujourd'hui mal comprise mal prises en
compte vraiment votre éclairage nous
sera d'une grande grande fertilité car
nous sommes parfois perplexe nous les
législateurs nous devons légiférer sur
des objectifs à 10 ans à 20 ans à 30 ans
en matière de logement en matière
d'artificialisation des sols en matière
de voiture thermique en voiture en
matière d'énergie sans toujours savoir
avoir disposer d'une évaluation sur les
conséquences macroéconomiques de novotes
et surtout et peut-être plus encore de
la somme des lois que nous adoptons les
unes après les autres sans négliger le
rôle majeur du progrès technique vous
remettez en cause le récit techno
optimiste selon lequel la transition
serait un long fleuve tranquille
perspective peu réjouissante dans
lesquelles il faut pourtant s'engager au
plus vite car plus nous que tardons plus
la transition est coûteuse ce qui
m'amène pour conclure à une question
simple qui s'adresse bien sûr à vous
trois comment réduire pour l'Europe et
pour la France le coût de cette
transition voire faire de cette
transition une opportunité pour de
nouveaux dans de nouveaux secteurs et
finalement une croissance plus sobre en
carbone et plus riche en emploi merci
beaucoup et dans l'ordre je sais
voilà prenez la parole dans l'ordre que
vous souhaitez en fonction des questions
qui ont été posées monsieur ferry je
vous vois prêt
c'est l'heure de l'alphabétique monsieur
le président
écoutez merci d'abord de nous nous
convier à participer à votre votre
réflexion
si vous avez énuméré les différents
postes d'enseignement que j'ai eu mais
c'est pas tout à fait simultané
donc ce que je pensais peut-être
utile c'est prendre un peu de chant
il y a des aspects conjoncturels à la
question que vous avez posée les
questions que vous avez posées il y a
des aspects beaucoup plus de
structurelles et moi j'avais envie de
partir de ces questions structuelles
parce que vous avez évoqué le marché
intérieur et vous avez dit en fait
ce travail de construction du marché
intérieur n'est pas achevé on peut être
que d'accord avec vous en même temps
il est clair que si on réfléchit à ce
que c'est que l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui et ce à quoi il est
confronté par rapport à la manière dont
on la voyait ils ont avant la crise
financière il y a 15 ans
on ne peut être que frappé par le fait
que elle a été très profondément
transformé et questionner par les
événements de ces 15 dernières années
alors il y a 15 ans on la voyait comme
un espace d'intégration un espace de
règles dans un monde de règles
et donc la question même c'est posé à
l'époque le Premier ministre Gordon
Brown c'est est-ce qu'on a encore besoin
l'Union européenne est-ce que c'est pas
au niveau global qu'il faut s'intégrer
bon aujourd'hui
cette vision a volée en éclat alors je
pense que la première chose c'est la
récurrence des crises on a quand même eu
depuis
un peu plus de 10 ans 3 3 crises crises
financière crise pandémique crise
énergétique aujourd'hui et
chrysiopolitique je vais venir
et un monde de règles c'est pas un
espace dominé par les règles c'est pas
adéquat véritablement pour répondre aux
crises la crise il faut du
discrétionnaire et donc c'est le défi
auquel le premier défi auquel a été
confronté l'Union européenne alors
dans la crise de la zone euro elle a
commencé par réagir très mal
avec en réagissant de manière
extraordinairement précautionneuse
jusqu'à arriver à la conclusion de cette
période très douloureuse qui a été le
whatever it takes de Mario Draghi donc
le fait de dire on affirme en fait le
discrétionnaire d'une certaine manière
d'un politique monétaire dans la crise
pandémique elle a très bien réagi la
très bien réagit en prenant tôt une
initiative de réponse et dans la crise
énergétique on a l'impression qu'on
retombe en arrière c'est à dire qu'on
est vous l'avez évoqué dans des
réactions nationales disparate une
grande difficulté à coordonner en partie
parce que évidemment les politiques
énergétiques c'est un domaine
traditionnellement de responsabiliser
nationale
et aujourd'hui on est sur des
trajectoires divergentes et on a marqué
entre la France et l'Allemagne sur ces
sur ces questions qui est qui est
préoccupant donc
première chose la récurrence des crises
et deuxième deuxième élément bien sûr
l'éruption du géopolitique et ça
c'est très violent parce que l'Union
vivait sur la séparation à peu près
complète du géopolitique et de
l'économie
et
plus exactement on avait une vision
géopolitique qui était évidemment à
l'origine du système international dont
l'Union européenne faisait partie mais à
l'intérieur de cette vision on avait
pris bien soin de séparer la partie
économique qui fonctionnait avec ses
propres règles et ses propres principes
de la partie géopolitique
c'est fini ce monde défini parce que le
sud global n'accepte plus en fait les
règles que nous avons tenté de lui
imposer enfin le fait que le l'OMC par
exemple une interlalisme OMC est en
jachère complète l'OMC n'est plus une
institution
fonctionnelle
l'affirmation du géopolitique qui ne se
réduit pas à l'affrontement entre la
Russie pardon la Chine et les États-Unis
et qui est beaucoup plus une tendance
beaucoup plus forte
et donc il vient percuter la primauté de
l'économie
et ça va probablement durer parce que
aujourd'hui l'espace de l'économie
continue d'exister mais il est plus
étroit et donc ça c'est une mise en
question forte de l'Union européenne
et enfin vous avez fait vous en avez
parlé l'autre la montée en puissance des
préoccupations climatiques et la
tentative pour l'Union européenne
d'affirmer une stratégie
vous avez un peu questionné disons dans
ses effets alors moi je ne questionne
pas dans ses effets je dis simplement
que il faut être conscient
du fait que dans un premier temps il est
probable
à mon avis très probable mais je
j'accepte d'être questionné là-dessus et
on va continuer à travailler dans le
cadre de la mission que m'a confié la
première ministre pour
essayer de préciser les premières
analyses que j'ai rendu public
oui alors non mais il y a alors pour
commencer à répondre mais sûrement on y
reviendra plus en détail je pense que
dans un premier temps c'est un on a
regardé beaucoup les impacts sur la
demande il y a aussi des impacts et plus
on accélère plus des impacts sur l'offre
vont se manifester pour être concrets ça
veut dire que du capital en place va
devoir être mis au rebut que des
qualifications
acquises vont devoir être perdu donc
c'est un peu de manière générale c'est
du on perd du capital on en regagne donc
à long terme je suis optimiste mais à
court terme je pense qu'il faut être
réaliste donc à horizon 10 ans il faut
être réaliste horizon de 20 ans ou 30
ans il y a il y a des raisons de penser
que qu'on a des on a des motifs d'être
optimiste
mais le langagement sur cette question
du pacte verte ça dépasse aussi ces
aspects ça par exemple ça pose la
question
du rôle respectif du marché des
initiatives publiques l'Union européenne
c'était quand même un espace disons de
libre concurrence comme on dit et on est
dans on est entré dans un monde
d'externalité comme disent des
économistes dans lesquelles
l'intervention publique est essentielle
et d'ailleurs elle ne la transition ne
se passerait pas sans intervention
publique et donc ça percute les règles
du commerce s'apperturbe sa percute les
Red budgétaires vas à percute tout un
ensemble d'éléments de l'Union
européenne
et donc pour pour terminer je crois que
ce qui se joue dans tout ça c'est une
redéfinition assez complète des
finalités des priorités et des modes
d'action de l'Union européenne et ça il
faut en être conscience c'est-à-dire
c'est pas
enfin on n'est plus centré sur
l'intégration d'entre nous on est centré
sur
la réponse aux défis globaux la réponse
aux yeux l'éruption du géopolitique et
des actions de type
politique climatique qui sont pas en
tant que tel des politiques
d'intégration mais qui dans le tel des
politiques se définissent par leur
finalité alors pour juste si vous me
permettez quelques quelques remarques
d'abord tout ça va assez dans le sens
des thèses traditionnellement françaises
il faut se garder
de
du triomphalisme de lubrise là-dessus ce
serait d'assez mauvaise aloi je pense
qu'il faut
reconnaître qu'on ne va pas changer le
code génétique de l'Union européenne
c'est à dire
pour
reprendre point longtemps j'étais parti
l'Union européenne c'est pas la volonté
du peuple parce que question de savoir
souveraineté européenne c'est une
formule brillante que je partage mais
enfin c'est aussi un oxymore donc
l'Union européenne c'est un espace de
droit donc la question c'est comment on
peut donner force donner plus de force
un espèce de droit c'est pas de
substituer d'utiliser questionnaire à au
droit
il faut aussi
se garder de l'idée que tout ça au fond
conforte une vision traditionnellement
un peu protectionniste que nous avions
de l'Union européenne ce qui est très
frappant aujourd'hui dans le la manière
dont on envisage
la transition écologique c'est que pour
les Français c'est une manière assez
naturellement de devenir autarcique ou
aussi autarcissique possible pour les
Allemands c'est une occasion de faire du
commerce international donc chacun
répond avec ses propres réflexes ou même
défi enfin c'est deux ces deux réponses
sont pas spontanément compatibles
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut prendre
garde en fait c'est à nous réflexions
cette affaire bon pour autant une
communauté de droit n'a pas de raison
d'être faible on a des instruments qui
sont des instruments de puissance la
politique commerciale la politique de la
concurrence la politique de
réglementation sont des instruments
puissants il faut les utiliser de
manière plus plus ferme
mais il faut pas s'engager
pour te faire image je pense que
l'Europe n'aurait aucun intérêt à
s'engager dans une politique commerciale
à la Trump
a intérêt à rester appuyé sur la force
du droit
je pense que il faut repenser évidemment
la question l'articulation entre
l'économie et géopolitique mais pas en
soumettant complètement l'économie que
j'ai politique il y a des circonstances
dans lesquelles il faut que le
géopolitique puisse intervenir mais de
manière aussi explicite et aussi
procéduralisée que possible de dire par
exemple sur la on a eu le débat sur la
politique de la concurrence je pense
qu'il faut que il puisse y avoir une
exception qui soit invoquée pour des
motifs géopolitiques
lorsqu'une décision est prise sur la
concurrence qui pose question mais il
faut que ce soit porté par quelqu'un
dans ce soit par exemple vous
représentant il faut que ça intervienne
explicitement il faut pas que chaque
décision en matière de politique de la
concurrence soit contaminée par cette
question du géopolitique
voilà et pour terminer sur un point sur
la crise énergétique
vous avez posé pas mal de questions je
pense que c'est une une menace sérieuse
pour les raisons que j'ai dites on est
parti dans des directions différentes on
a une difficulté importante à se mettre
d'accord entre les Français et les
Allemands
nous pensons que la volatilité des prix
est dangereuse et qu'il faut donner
priorité à limiter la volatilité des
prix les Allemands pensent que les
incitations
aux économies d'énergie sont importantes
et donc il faut éviter de créer un
système dans lequel on font on incite
pas aux économies d'énergie je pense que
les deux préoccupations sont légitimes
et entre les deux il faut trouver un
compromis je pense que ce compromis est
possible bon on peut y revenir dans sur
la manière de de le construire mais je
pense que c'est tout à fait tout à fait
important et
là on est face à une crise immédiate qui
est dangereuse pour pour l'Union
européenne pour cette raison que enfin
elle peut se fracasser sur cette
question de la crise énergétique et des
réactions divergentes que ça suscite
entre les différents pays
merci
monsieur le Président merci Jean pour
ces propos que je partage à 99% et je
veux pas essayer de parler du 1% oui
mais je sais pas si c'est si c'est
nécessaire
je pense que le premier point il est
effectivement très important
l'Union européenne la construction
européenne a été mise au défi depuis 15
ans
d'un certain nombre de crises
qui faut quand même pas le cacher
remettre en cause un certain nombre
d'éléments et d'analyse qui avait
présidé à sa à sa conception et à sa
mise en oeuvre et donc qui
oblige à la fois à faire évoluer le
projet et aussi à admettre que il y a
des limites il y a des risques à
franchir ses limites à voulant en faire
jouer ou endosser au projet européen des
choses pour lesquelles il n'a pas été
conçu et et que il y a un double risque
en fait d'abord de ne pas traiter les
problèmes auquel on fait face et ensuite
de mal les traiter donc tout ça sont des
questions assez importantes je pense que
l'irruption des géopolitiques et
véritablement
l'affaire de l'année 2022 et que elle
est
peut-être beaucoup plus profonde que ne
l'a été la crise sanitaire qui au fond
la crise sanitaire a été l'occasion de
montrer que les instruments qui avaient
été compris et mis en place après la
crise de la zone euro en 2012
été effectivement opérationnel et
fonctionné et que la solidarité entre
les États européens autour des questions
budgétaires de poser aucun problème que
le risque d'un état voyou qui abuserait
de ses partenaires pour accumuler des
déficits et les pousser à devoir le
renflouer c'était des étaient des
visions de l'esprit et que il y avait
bien au contraire une vraie communauté
de destins a fait vivre et que
finalement les choses étaient assez
faciles de ce point de vue là non pas
que la pandémie était facile mais
elle a montré que en fait il y avait
moyen de donner corps à cette solidarité
européenne assez simplement et assez
rapidement en rencontrant d'ailleurs je
pense plutôt la sentiment de l'opinion
publique des opinions publiques en
Europe la question géopolitique elle est
beaucoup plus profonde parce que elle
est plus en contradiction avec le avec
le projet européen le projet européen
c'est en quelque sorte un enfant de la
fin de l'histoire de la fin de la guerre
froide de l'effondrement de l'URSS et de
l'idée que on allait entrer dans un
monde dans lequel il y aurait une espèce
de souverain invisible qui allait
permettre de définir des règles et que
chacun allait être en charge de faire
respecter ses règles et surtout aller
respecter ses règles et globalement en
fait dans ce monde là que l'on soit
Suisse ou à Singapour ou au sein d'un
grand pays comme la Chine ou les
États-Unis en fait on aurait été traité
de la même façon puisque les règles
s'appliquent indifféremment de de qui
vous êtes et donc que on pouvait être
dans un univers où on pouvait imaginer
la dissolution des des grandes
institutions et que de ce point de vue
là le projet européen pouvait se réduire
à
ce qu'il était peut-être originellement
donc un monde d'intégration un monde de
règles une mise en commun d'un certain
nombre d'éléments autour de ses règles
mais fondamentalement pouvoir laisser
vivre chacun des États membres son
histoire sachant qu'il n'y en avait pas
en fait d'histoire mais bon voilà le le
ce qui était intéressant dans cette
Europe là c'est que
la dispute disons entre la France et
l'Allemagne
s'évanouissait en fait elle n'était pas
résolue mais voilà chacun pouvait faire
un peu comme il voulait après tout si
les Français voulaient développer ou
rester attachés à l'idée d'une d'une
nation et si les Allemands voulaient
être mercantiliste après tout les deux
étaient possibles et on pouvait vivre
comme ça je pense que la crise
géopolitique dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons mais à mal c'est ces éléments
je pense que elle elle donne
elle donne tort au modèle allemand
qui a fait probablement des mauvais
choix géopolitiques indépendance
vis-à-vis de la Russie la dépendance
énergétique
sont des sont des mauvais choix la
dépense l'indépendance aussi de
l'Allemagne vis-à-vis de son commerce et
donc de ses clients qu'ils soient
chinois américains ou
[Musique]
dans des pays comme la Russie
pose un certain nombre de difficultés à
l'Allemagne et la met face à des
contradictions qui sont difficiles à
gérer dans la géopolitique de 2022 il y
a pas simplement l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie ou la continuation
le réallumage de la guerre en Ukraine il
y a aussi par exemple
[Musique]
c'est un tout petit peu avant mais la
fin du mandat de Trump remplacée par un
Joe Biden et avec quand même le fait que
ça n'a pas changé grand chose dans la
position des États-Unis et puis d'abord
ensuite aussi que Trump n'est pas non
plus définitivement écarté et encore
moins le trampisme de la scène
géopolitique que la Chine aussi
s'affirme dans cet univers là comme
jouant son jeu
en exposant ses intérêts et en ayant un
comportement peut-être infiniment moyen
irrationnel que celui de Poutine mais en
ayant un comportement qui n'est pas non
plus universaliste on va dire comme on
aurait pu qu'on aurait pu l'aimer ou
comme peut-être l'administration Obama
souhaitée que la Chine se comporte donc
ces éléments là s'affirment je pense que
il faut aussi accepter la mort de l'OMC
mais pas simplement en tant que
événement assez important mais aussi en
tant que symptômes de cette époque dans
lequel précisément l'idée même de ces
constructions
euh comme l'OMC donc des constructions
participative d'une certaine façon ou
chaque État avait le droit de de définir
de codéfinir les règles et de et de
codéfinir les modes d'application est un
univers qui est dépassé et dans lequel
la possibilité de conflit
quel que soit leur intensité
devient en fait un
mode réglé les rapports de puissance
entre les entre les continents et de ce
point de vue là le projet européen
paraît assez dénudé face à ces questions
la question de savoir comment on va
l'incarner et comment on va le
augmenter sa possibilité d'être dans ce
nouveau monde est une question qui est à
mon avis est ouverte
certains pourraient penser que il nous
faut du fédéralisme
mais on voit bien que pour des tas de
raisons et en particulier celles qui est
que on a promis qu'il n'y aurait pas de
fédéralisme ça va être assez difficile à
faire passer on peut avoir une forme de
coopération entre des États membres
européens qui partagent des intérêts
bien compris et qui du coup est
co-exerce cette souveraineté c'est
probablement un scénario plus
vraisemblable mais il reste encore à
faire vivre et la question par exemple
énergétique en Europe nous montre que ce
n'est pas si simple en tout cas ça va
demander à la France de ne pas triompher
et de d'aller écouter appuyer et
chercher et trouver des compromis avec
ses partenaires européens je pense que
c'est extrêmement important parce que si
l'Allemagne se trouve dans une position
difficile
ça ne veut pas forcément dire que du
coup la France est dans une position
facile
voilà alors face à ces face à ces
questions et je pense que là vraiment la
question géopolitique est extrêmement
importante et surtout la question
géopolitique ce qu'elle va nous obliger
à traiter c'est cette question de
divergence entre la France la France et
l'Allemagne et qu'on ne pourra plus
traiter comme un problème secondaire ou
comme un problème académique qu'on
discute dans des livres ou dans des
Colocs en disant ben voilà ils sont pas
pareils et il y a plein de choses qui
nous le montrent mais là voilà
maintenant on est rentré dans quelque
chose de extrêmement concret qui se
traduit quand il s'agit d'acheter des
avions quand il s'agit d'investir dans
des avions ou quand il s'agit de de
mettre en place un certain nombre de
mesures pour répondre à la crise
énergétique ce qui a été proposé par la
Commission européenne ne me paraît pas
et là je vais peut-être 1% d'écart avec
Jean-Phi Zani ferry me paraît pas un
recul en arrière je pense que au
contraire c'est peut-être le signe que
on peut avancer vers des compromis alors
résumons un peu le compromis la France
voulait qu'on bloque les prix du gaz
je trouvais que cette approche était une
approche pertinente et intéressante
parce que effectivement bloquer les prix
du gaz c'était pouvoir dire aux Russes
nous ne subirons pas le raquette que
vous voulez nous imposer nous ne
financerons pas votre votre gaz enfin
votre guerre et puis par ailleurs nous
avons de fortes raisons de penser que
vous manipulez les prix du gaz en jouant
sur les quantités que vous livrez ou que
vous ne livrez pas peut-être un sabotant
des gazoducs en faisant un certain
nombre d'effets d'annonces en coupant le
gaz à certains pays pas à d'autres etc
donc vous manipulez visiblement le prix
du gaz or voilà c'est écrit dans les
règles de l'Union européenne quand un
prix manipulé ou quand on soupçonne
qu'il est manipulé on est tout à fait
autorisé légitime à suspendre ce prix et
à l'administrer et donc l'administration
du prime pas assez une une réponse assez
logique dans cette guerre un peu étrange
que nous avons avec la Russie qui n'est
pas une guerre militaire sur le champ de
bataille mais qui n'est quand même eu un
conflit
tout à fait caractérisé et que de ce
point de vue là c'était effectivement
une alors
je partageais cette analyse et même dire
que je l'ai même poussé auprès d'un
certain nombre de personnes
et je pense que effectivement la
position allemande est une position
aujourd'hui et la position la position
de compromis la Commission européenne
est une position meilleure pour quelle
raison parce que en fait ce que propose
la Commission européenne c'est de dire
on va pas figer le prix du gaz parce que
si on fige le prix du gaz on prend le
risque et c'est un risque réel
des livraisons de gaz en quantité
alors
c'est effectivement un raisonnement tout
à fait juste quand on fixe le prix c'est
les quantités qui vont s'ajuster et
même si ça peut paraître aux Français
pas très grave qu'on arrête les
livraisons de gaz ou en tout cas celle
qui viennent de Russie par exemple parce
que on trouvera toujours du gaz en
Algérie qui sont des vieux amis et qui
nous doivent cette livraison de gaz
absolument quoi qu'il en soit
même si on pouvait penser ça je pense
qu'en fait il y avait une grave erreur
d'analyse derrière et que le fait d'un
rationnement quantitatif massif à
l'échelle de l'Europe aurait été
véritablement un problème et pas
simplement un rationnement quantitatif
du gaz qui arrive de Russie mais aussi
si on fixe le prix à un niveau qui est
bas le fait que les transporteurs de gaz
liquifier au lieu de s'arrêter en Europe
iront au Japon ou en Asie plutôt qu'en
plutôt qu'en Europe et donc que ça peut
produire effectivement une rupture des
approvisionnements de gaz le compromis
européen il est de dire plutôt que de
brutalement fixer un prix
en fait ce qu'on va faire c'est que on
va essayer d'acheter du gaz en commun
pour
imposer notre monopsone le fait qu'on
soit un acheteur unique sur le marché du
gaz et jouer de notre force pour pouvoir
négocier et sécuriser des
approvisionnements gaz y compris en
passant des contrats à moyen terme ou à
long terme sur le gaz
on va par ailleurs aussi s'autoriser à
utiliser de façon stratégique
les stocks qui pourront permettre de
dire à un moment donné nous jugeons que
le prix est beaucoup trop élevé et donc
nous vendons des stocks et nous inondons
le marché de stock pour faire baisser le
prix du gaz y compris en annonçant à
l'avance le prix auquel cela se produira
alors évidemment ça demande d'avoir des
stocks mais tant qu'on a des stocks on
peut le faire ce que ça ce que ça veut
dire quand même implicitement c'est que
on délègue une gestion des stocks de
façon stratégique à une émanation de
l'Europe dans lequel chaque pays
évidemment sera représenté mais il faut
quand même avoir une voie commune on
peut pas dire ah bah non mais moi je
vais garder mes stocks parce que je
pense que la situation va être plus
compliquée mais il faut être aussi prêt
à réagir à une situation où l'hiver est
particulièrement sévère et où on a
besoin de beaucoup de gaz et où on est
prêt à le payer très cher parce que au
fond voilà on sera faire la part entre
cette guerre étrange que nous menons
avec la Russie d'une part et puis
d'autre part ce que ça coûte
économiquement socialement en France
donc de ce point de vue là la proche de
la Commission on peut la juger plus flou
plus vague avec quelque chose quelques
éléments qui sont peu explicites et
peut-être qu'ils cachent en fait des
manques mais par rapport à la
proposition initiale française je pense
qu'il faut accepter que c'est plutôt
supérieur et que ça effectivement c'est
de nature a pu être un compromis dans
lequel on peut embarquer les Allemands
on peut embarquer les Italiens les
Néerlandais et avoir quelque chose qui
du coup aura un poids simplement même
pas un effet d'annonce donc là aussi il
faut être prêt à accepter ce genre de
choses dans notre dialogue entre
guillemets avec la Russie
cette cette avancée peut faire bouger un
atome de choses parce que elle montre
que la tantelle la tentative ou la
technique ou la tactique de la Russie
qui était de diviser l'Europe et
d'essayer alimenter les divisions en
fait ne fonctionne pas et que face à ça
il y a des compromis qui s'élaborent et
qui même s'ils sont insatisfaisants par
certains points en tout cas montre que
la stratégie de division ne fonctionne
pas c'est aussi extrêmement important de
dire ce genre de choses pas simplement à
la Russie mais aussi aux États-Unis les
États-Unis ne l'oublions pas dans cette
histoire de prix du gaz ne risque moins
le rationnement quantitatif en fait ils
sont producteurs et donc ils peuvent
même y échapper complètement et par
contre ils bénéficie d'un prix du gaz
plutôt élevé donc de ce point de vue là
nos intérêts sont divergents et donc il
faut pouvoir parler aux Américains en
leur disant nos intérêts divergents mais
nous on connaît nos propres intérêts
donc de ce point de vue là il y a plutôt
une avancée alors le deuxième point
alors il y a des tas de points qu'on
pourrait énoncer mais le deuxième point
que je voudrais faire
sans parler de transition
environnementale mais là je rejoins à
100% jean-pizaine ferry je pense que il
y a pas il y a aujourd'hui il y a pas à
discuter de de
quelle politique on doit faire il faut
vraiment s'attacher à d'abord en mesurer
les conséquences ensuite aussi à le
faire parce que
s'il y a une dimension macroéconomique à
la transition énergétique la transition
énergétique c'est une somme incroyable
de différentes couches qu'il faut
mobiliser tout ensemble qui sont toutes
disparates pas toujours complémentaires
pas toujours sans contradiction les unes
avec les autres et qu'il faut articuler
et qu'il faut expliquer et qu'il faut
mettre en oeuvre et qu'il faut réévaluer
au fur et à mesure qu'elles sont mises
en oeuvre il y a un travail considérable
les lois que vous votez ne sont qu'un
tout petit aperçu de ce qui va
être votre travail dans les années qui
viennent ce sera considérable et il y
aura écoute aller-retour beaucoup
d'évolution beaucoup de confusion aussi
et donc il faut se préparer à tout ça en
essayant de d'anticiper et de réduire au
maximum cette confusion donc le point
que je voudrais faire c'est sur la
question de la de la alors à la fois de
la dette publique mais aussi de la
politique monétaire et puis j'aurais je
passerai pour la Charlie juste après
le
dans la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes confrontés à une inflation et une
crise géopolitique l'un est en liée en
partie avec l'autre nous oblige à avoir
une politique monétaire qui doit remplir
deux objectifs c'est d'abord être
crédible dans sa capacité à lutter
contre l'inflation ne pas trop en faire
parce que cette crise énergétique est
récessive et donc il n'est pas
nécessaire de rajouter la récession à la
récession mais surtout éviter tout
risque de fragments fragmentation en
Europe et le le éviter le risque de
fragmentation en Europe c'est important
à la fois pour le projet européen pour
bien comprendre les conséquences de la
de la crise de l'euro en 2012 et de ne
pas perdre les acquis qui ont été
révélés au moment de la crise sanitaire
mais aussi parce que la non
fragmentation donc le fait que chaque
État puisse emprunter un taux sans payer
une prime par rapport à par exemple
l'Allemagne qui soit élevé c'est un
élément essentiel de la cohérence
géopolitique de l'Europe et si l'Europe
n'apparaît pas comme un lieu dans lequel
chaque État pourra
garantir son financement un taux
acceptable il sera tenté de répondre aux
sirènes
aujourd'hui de la Russie demain de la
Chine ou après-demain des États-Unis et
donc cette cohérence elle est aussi la
responsabilité de l'Europe et elle
impose une politique monétaire très
particulière madame Lagarde n'a pas
toujours été extrêmement clair sur ces
points là je pense en pratique
les instruments anti fragments anti
fragmentation qui ont été annoncés sont
des avancées extrêmement importantes
extrêmement positives
mais je pense que c'est là aussi un
point sur lequel le projet européen se
joue et que si on trébuche sur cette
question là on risque d'avoir en cascade
tout un tas de conséquences extrêmement
négatives sur la cohérence européenne
merci c'est intéressant sur la politique
monétaire on aurait plein de questions à
poser on sera peut-être l'occasion d'une
autre audition
alors
monsieur viplôse vous nous entendez
toujours bien
je vous entends très bien
c'est à vous
merci beaucoup écoutez c'est un grand
plaisir pour moi d'être présent ici à
distance c'est un des bienfaits de du
covid c'est qu'on peut maintenant on a
des instruments pour faire ça et je suis
absolument ravi
étant installé depuis quelques temps en
Suisse c'est toujours compliqué de venir
assister à une séance
un moment donné et grâce à cette
nouvelle technologie je peux être enfin
avec vous et j'en suis ravi et honoré
dans ma présentation comme je suis un
macroéconomiste je parlerai plus des
questions d'intendance que des questions
structurelles qui ont été abordées par
mes prédécesseurs longuement par Jean
mais j'aurai quelques remarques à faire
de mon point de vue la situation
actuelle
est caractérisée par un niveau
générale en Europe et en France d'un
niveau élevé de dette publique
à un moment où on a des nouveaux besoins
de dépenses publiques très substantielle
et donc il y a au départ un conflit
entre le point de la situation qu'on
mérite du passé et le besoin qui se
présente à nous et qui ont déjà été
présentés par Jean et par Xavier
je vais commencer par parler de la dette
publique ou d'aide publique et ensuite
des dépenses et budget européen etc
les niveaux actuels de dette publique
dans une grande partie des pays
européens pas tous mais une grande
partie
ces niveaux actuels nous contraignant
pour la plupart des pays on le voit avec
les 200 milliards annoncés par
l'Allemagne et qui ont amené l'Italie à
se plaindre que il pouvait pas faire ça
comme ça donc c'est une contrainte et
c'est aussi une source de fragilité dont
on commence à parler au fur et à mesure
où la BCE fait monter les taux d'intérêt
les pays endettés commencent à sentir le
poids de leur endettement et donc il y a
une source de fragilité on n'a pas envie
de recommencer la crise de
2010 2012
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec la
situation de départ la dette qu'on a
hérité du passé on connaît trois moyens
de réduire les dettes et malheureusement
trois seulement un c'est l'inflation qui
sous certaines conditions fait fondre la
dette ça a été pas mal utilisé plus ou
moins implicitement dans le passé
c'est devient plus difficile parce que
les marchés sont plus sophistiqués les
les sont protégés en partie contre la
montée de l'inflation donc c'est peu
probable et de toute façon les banques
centrales que nous avons aujourd'hui
dans les pays développés ne prendront
aucun risque sur l'inflation on les voit
à qui agissent et donc elle ne joueront
pas ce jeu là j'en suis convaincu
l'autre moyen de réduire les déficits
les dettes publiques c'est d'avoir des
surplus budgétaires année après année
après année jusqu'à ce que les dettes
reviennent à des niveaux raisonnables
c'est
[Musique]
la c'est l'approche virtuelle virtuelle
prenait entre autres par l'Allemagne
mais pas uniquement je rappellerai
simplement qu'en France notre la
dernière année où notre budget a été
équilibré c'était
1973 donc bientôt 50 ans l'idée qu'on
peut faire pendant une décennie ou deux
des surplus budgétaires pour réduire nos
têtes est implosible
dans un certain nombre de pays et je
pense que la France en fait partie on
n'a pas on n'a pas eu une performance
superbe actuelle même sans compter les
défis actuels dont je vais parler tout à
l'heure la troisième solution pour
réduire la dette c'est de les
restructurer c'est une intervention un
peu autoritaire qui consiste à
taxer en gros les détenteurs de dettes
d'une manière
ou d'une autre si possible l'élégante
pas trop destructrice alors maintenant
que j'ai fait la liste de ça vous voyez
que la stratégie dominante
officiellement actuellement qui est de
faire des des surplus budgétaires ça
fait 15 ans qu'on parle de ça en disant
pas cette année mais l'année prochaine
ça ira mieux et dans deux ans ça ira
encore mieux donc on fera ça à ce
moment-là et à jouer avec ce jeu-là
pendant 15 ans ça n'a pas marché l'année
prochaine ça n'est pas aller mieux on a
eu tout un tas de crises que Jean et
Xavier ont abandonné
qu'ils ont abondamment rappelé et l'idée
que ça ira mieux l'année prochaine c'est
un vœu qu'on peut formuler tous mais
c'est pas une promesse et donc c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va réduire les dettes
publiques donc il reste à mon avis un
seul moyen c'est la restructuration des
dettes publiques c'est un sujet
absolument tabou en Europe on ne peut en
parler avec personne et d'ailleurs à
Paris non plus chaque fois que je
soulève la question ça paraît
complètement irréaliste mais je ne vois
rien d'autre sinon continuez avec des
dettes qui sont extrêmement élevés et
dangereux donc ça c'est c'est la
question il y a des méthodes pour
restructurer des dettes c'est je peux en
parler plus terriblement si ça vous
intéresse mais je veux pas
abuser juste une remarque en passant la
les pays européens ne sont pas les seuls
à avoir des dettes publiques élevées
parmi les pays développés la dette
publique aux États-Unis de 140% du PIB
pareil en Grande-Bretagne le Japon est
hors norme avec 250% et il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude financière sur la dette de
ces pays encore que la Grande-Bretagne a
montré que il peut y avoir des
inquiétudes quand il y a des
erreurs grossières qui sont commises en
Europe c'est pas du tout la même
situation parce que il a pas de banc
parce que la Banque centrale européenne
n'est pas automatiquement prête à
soutenir les dettes publiques donc il y
a eu des progrès énormes qui ont été
rappelés en 2012 on avance dans cette
voie mais on n'est pas là et donc il y a
une fragilité particulière au pays de la
zone euro qui n'ont pas leur propre
banque centrale nationale pour venir les
secourir s'il y a une crise financière
comme on l'a vu en Grande-Bretagne il y
a un mois
maintenant donc là ce que je veux faire
apparaître c'est qu'on est dans une
situation
difficile dangereuse et qu'on n'a pas
abordé encore dans aucun pays en fait la
discussion de la seule manière de
progresser sur cette endettement
excessif deuxième question les dépenses
nouvelles à venir donc elles ont déjà
été abordées par même prédécesseur j'en
vois 5 il y a le changement climatique
et donc le rapport de gens a mis les
points sur les i ça ne sera pas gratuit
ça va coûter relativement cher pas
énormément mais ça va coûter cher
le problème avec le change avec les
approches sur le changement climatique
c'est que pour des raisons politiques
les gilets jaunes etc
rares sont les pays qui sont pré
envisager une taxe carbone qui a
l'avantage d'être simple de résoudre
tous les problèmes pratiquement d'un
seul coup donc on est parti plus tôt sur
des mécanismes de subvention qui soulève
des problèmes
d'analyses c'est-à-dire où qu'est-ce
qu'on subvention qu'est-ce qu'on
subventionne tout n'est pas doit pas
être subventionné il y a des
enthousiasmes qui apparaissent portés
par différents lobbys qui sont très
coûteux et très peu efficaces
et
comment on finance ces subventions
évidemment
tout un tas de questions qui qui
jaillissent et qui ont été élaborés par
Jean simplement du fait que on n'arrive
pas à faire les taxes une vraie taxe
carbone alors sur la tasse carbone je
suis pas complètement désespéré et c'est
le mécanisme d'ajustement aux frontières
qui est en fait permet d'avoir une taxe
carbone et une on en a des morceaux ici
et là qui est un mécanisme absolument
indispensable même en l'absence de taxe
carbone même si on fait tout par des
subventions c'est un mécanisme
indispensable
et les conflits avec nos partenaires que
ce soit les États-Unis ou avec les pays
en développement sont des conflits qui
est mon avis ne sont pas sérieux parce
que eux aussi devront passer à ça les
États-Unis maintenant à embarquer avec
le plan
ira
Joe Biden ce sont aussi lancés dans les
subventions
de manière très protectionniste donc
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel sur
lequel la main ne doit absolument pas
trembler deuxième dépense nouvelle c'est
la crise énergétique c'est un transfert
que nous devons faire vis-à-vis des pays
producteurs donc c'est peut-être un bien
fait pour les raisons de lutte contre le
jugement de changement climatique je
crois que ça a eu déjà un effet
profond sur l'ensemble des citoyens qui
ont compris que
les prix de l'énergie
doivent augmenter vont augmenter et qui
sont plus près d'accepter
de soutenir la lutte contre le
changement climatique même si ça leur
coûte c'est en train de goûter mais de
toute façon ça va coûter aux autorités
publiques qui va falloir protéger les
populations les plus infectées et ce
qu'il faudra simplement la seule chose
que je veux dire s'il faudra le faire
beaucoup mieux en ciblant
les les ménages nécessiteux et pas en
distribuant à tout le monde 30 centimes
par litre comment le fait actuellement
là c'est un problème administratif le
ministère des Finances nous dit ne pas
être capable de cibler je trouve ça
absolument extraordinaire qu'on puisse
pas avancer rapidement dans cette
direction troisième
troisième dépense à venir les dépenses
de santé donc
le covid a montré que nos systèmes de
santé s'il y en avait besoin ne sont pas
au point en France il y a une véritable
crise de la santé mais c'est pas le seul
pays les mêmes causes ont tendance à
faire les mêmes produire les mêmes
effets donc il va y avoir des dépenses
importantes dans les années à venir pour
avoir un système de santé qui correspond
à nos besoins et aux capacités
techniques dont on dispose quatrième
source de dépenses si on n'y prend pas
garde c'est la question des retraites
avec une population vieillissante j'ai
pas besoin d'assister là-dessus mais il
y a une source potentielle importante de
dépenses publiques augmentées dernier
dernier point depuis l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la par la Russie on a
compris que les dépenses de défense
nationale doivent augmenter elles
devront augmenter et tous les pays
européens voteront les augmenter je
pense donc là ça va être encore une
pression nouvelle sur le budget et donc
simplement dans la dans la mesure où on
a des dettes et que pour réduire les
dettes il faut réduire les déficits
publics et pour réduire les disciples
publics il faudrait réduire sans doute
une partie des dépenses non essentielles
qu'on n'a pas été capable de faire dans
le passé et on a des dépenses nouvelles
qui arrivent et qui va bien falloir
caser quelque part et financer d'une
manière ou d'une autre et donc il y a
une situation extrêmement difficile et
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on perçoit la
gravité du bouclage de des besoins et
des moyens dont on dispose sur le budget
européen mais il y a eu le le programme
de reprise que la Commission appelle du
doux nom de Next Generation you ça a été
ça a été une divine surprise pour la
première fois on a construit
de manière pratique ponctuelle un vrai
budget avec des vrais ressources et d'un
mécanisme de distribution de ses
ressources donc ça c'est une ivoire une
innovation on a promis qu'il y en aurait
pas d'autres mais personne en Europe ne
pas ne doute que quand on crée un
instrument il a tendance à faire des
petits donc c'est quelque chose
d'important mais la faire n'est pas
n'est pas gagné encore d'abord le
programme actuel doit faire ses preuves
et c'est pas gagné des d'avance
il est il est compliqué il est
bureaucratique il est conditionné à
plein de choses donc c'est pas
complètement sûr que ça sera un succès
si ça l'est pas il manque pas de
personnes et de pays qui qui
manifesteront leur hostilité et faut-il
le rappeler ce programme n'est pas
financé pour l'heure actuelle ou pas
entièrement financé donc il y a un
artifice comptable qui fait que c'est
une dette de collective de la Commission
européenne c'est pas la date de la dette
des pays membres mais c'est la dette des
pays de toute façon il faudra payer ça
donc il y a quand même un vrai problème
qui se pose sur la construction de cette
opération qui est quand même une grande
innovation historique alors c'est est-ce
que est-ce qu'on peut imaginer d'autres
programmes similaire et je crois que
plusieurs des questions que vous avez
posées porter là-dessus je crois que sur
le changement climatique ça serait
probablement
possible et souhaitable tous les pays
ont le même problème
à des degrés divorc divers mais tous les
pays ont fait face au même problème tous
les pays n'ont pas les mêmes moyens de
d'enclencher des politiques adéquates et
donc c'est un peu comme le covid tous
les pays avaient le même problème et
tout je n'avais pas les mêmes moyens et
c'est ça qui a amené à la création de ce
programme donc en principe ça serait
justifié et
on peut qu'on va y arriver un petit peu
pour Lost
vous nous avez soumis un certain nombre
de subventions je suis beaucoup plus
sceptique parce que pour faire des
programmes communs il y a des conditions
pour que ça marche et que ce soit
acceptable
mais de collègues ont abandonné
abondamment
montrait des des différences
d'appréciations entre la France et
l'Allemagne sera un certain nombre de
questions sur les questions d'un budget
commun il y a la différence la distance
est très importante mais c'est pas la
France et l'Allemagne contre l'Allemagne
c'est le sud contre le nord ou le Nord
contre le sud c'est une les divergences
sont profondes elles vont au-delà de ces
deux pays et les raisons sont simples
les pays du Nord ont été relativement
vertueux et on démarre de manœuvre
budgétaire importante et pays du Sud
l'ombre a été ils ont des dettes
publiques et les pays du Nord suspectent
toujours les pays du Sud
que les pays du Sud essaye de mettre la
main dans la poche les pays du Nord
c'est pas complètement
erroné et les décisions sont très
profondes et dépassent la France et
l'Allemagne
pour terminer je voudrais faire quelques
remarques parce que c'est une question
qui a été posée sur le pack de stabilité
donc la commission vient de faire
ces propositions je veux pas rentrer
dans le détail je vais simplement vous
dire en deux mots ce que j'en pense dans
les propositions de la Commission
européenne il y a des progrès importants
ils arrêtent de se focaliser sur le
déficit budgétaire année après année
mais ils veulent regarder la tête sur
une plus longue période un certain
nombre de nous défendaient cette idée
depuis très longtemps
c'est ce que les principes économiques
enseignent et c'est un gros progrès mais
il y a beaucoup de dans le projet de la
Commission et un certain nombre de trous
dans la raquette si je peux dire
qui
que je peux développer si vous êtes
intéressé mais que je vais résumer en un
mot il y a une tentative très nette de
prise de contrôle de la Commission
européenne qui elle veut au contraire
que les pays se sentent plus
propriétaire de ce nouveau pack de
stabilité dans dans le détail des de ces
propositions c'est très clair que tout
sera contrôlé serait contre les par
Bruxelles qui est le pays les pays
membres seront encore moins auront
encore moins à dire pour pour défendre
leur ce qu'ils pensent être les intérêts
et donc cette proposition de réforme est
un mélange comme toujours de bonnes
choses et de mauvaises choses et je
m'arrêterai là-dessus
bien merci écoutez pour ces exposés très
complets alors il nous reste allez je
vais dire 22 minutes parce qu'après il
faut qu'on soit à 15h au garde-à-vous
dans la dans la salle des missiles
puisque ce sont les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement on peut
prendre quelques questions et je crois
qu'il y avait franchement
oui merci
le président
messieurs merci d'abord pour vous pour
vous exposer vous vous l'avez dit et on
le sait tous les générations futures
vont subir un changement climatique dont
l'intensité dépendra des sacrifices des
politiques auxquelles nous nous
consentirons pour affronter nos
responsabilités jusqu'où allez selon
vous pour renforcer la prise en compte
des impacts à long terme de nos actions
et de leur soutenir soutenabilité
comment donner du poids au long terme
sans sacrifier le court terme quel est
votre position à l'égard par exemple de
propositions comme celle de de Monsieur
Gaulier par rapport au taux
d'actualisation à intégrer dans les
modèles de décision des acteurs où la
valeur du carbone autrement peut-être
vous l'avez évoqué que déterminé par le
système européen ets actuel si on
considère ces deux ces deux notions
actualisation et coûts du carbone comme
des indicateurs de pilotage de l'action
comment les faire adopter par les
parties prenantes état col entreprise
citoyens est-ce que éventuellement la
réponse à ça est en légiférant je vous
remercie
question la première question peut-être
à Jean Pisani Ferri dans votre triptyque
vous parlez de la succession des crises
l'éruption du géopolitique et la montée
des préoccupations climatiques rien et
dans vos propos 3 sur la question
d'internet et de l'émergence de
l'économie numérique est-ce que ça veut
dire que c'est un épiphénomène pour vous
ou est-ce que c'est à lire à l'intérieur
des d'un des deux d'un des trois
en jeu et la deuxième question par
rapport à ce que disait Xavier Timbaud
ce que vous ce que vous proposez pour le
gaz finalement c'est ce qu'on a mis en
place au niveau européen avec pour
traiter de la pandémie avec les
médicaments
donc est-ce que ça
légitime pas finalement cette union
européenne de droit dont parlait Jean
Pisani Ferri et ça permet peut-être de
relire
la capacité d'intervention de l'Union
dans les pour faire face à ces enjeux
merci
merci monsieur le Président j'ai été
tout à fait passionné par par vos trois
exposés très grandes valeurs qui donnent
un point de vue
un peu en hauteur de tout ce que nous
tout ce que nous vivons moi j'aimerais
vous apporter une contribution mais fort
modeste
d'un historien qui regarde ça sur le
temps très très long les 2000 ans de
l'Occident et
quand on quand on regarde ce qui a été
l'histoire de l'évolution des
civilisations pendant très longtemps
elles se sont contentés de la force
humaine de la force animale de la force
du vent et de la force de l'eau ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui les énergies
renouvelables et finalement on
s'aperçoit que la rupture elle arrive
très tard elle arrive au XVIIIe siècle
avec ce qu'on appelait la révolution
industrielle et l'émergence de nouvelles
formes d'énergie
charbon pétrole gaz dont on va être
obligé de sortir sentir et quand on
regarde ça sur 2011 on se dit finalement
que c'est juste une parenthèse de trois
siècles et que pendant très longtemps
quasiment 17 siècles l'Occident a connu
une croissance très modeste réellement
mais très modeste est-ce que la
fermeture de cette parenthèse
énergétique elle va pas nous ramener un
mode de croissance des civilisations qui
étaient celui excenté c'est à dire une
croissance modeste et comment nos
sociétés qui sont habituées à d'autres
formes de croissance peuvent s'adapter
aujourd'hui à une croissance et je
rejoins votre votre propos liminaire
rappelé par la présidente prima comment
on peut s'habituer à des croissances qui
sont sans doute beaucoup plus
compatibles avec ce qui a été de
l'histoire de nos civilisations merci
Serge Mérillou
merci
mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
les intervenants l'habitude la question
je me pose c'est les crises auxquelles
est confronté l'Europe
crise énergétique un choc inflationniste
etc
ne sont-elles pas une opportunité
pour créer un choc et mettre en place
les réformes que l'on n'arrive pas à
mettre en place dans une Europe à XPI
dans lequel dans lequel on ne bouge rien
ou très difficilement est-ce que c'est
pas l'occasion de redonner à la haut
puissance publique
de redonner le poids que le marché a
confisqué progressivement à la puissance
publique voilà donc en clair est-ce
qu'on n'a pas finalement parce que on
dit toujours que les guerres sont
toujours malheureuses mais sont toujours
une opportunité qui permettent de
redessiner de façon conséquente un
nouveau paysage voilà donc ma question
c'est n'est-ce pas une opportunité à
défaut de dire que ça pourrait être une
chance
merci
vous avez abondamment évoqué la
situation
géopolitique et les conséquences qu'elle
engendre sur le fonctionnement l'Union
européenne parmi les conséquences il y a
le retour de la question de
l'élargissement et cette question de
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne
avec son décalage vers l'Est pose aussi
la question de nos institutions
européennes la question des traités la
question des modalités de décision en
particulier celle de la règle de lumière
limitée or les uns et les autres que
vous avez dans vos démonstrations
rappelez les difficultés à mettre tout
le monde d'accord au sein de la table
européenne donc est-ce que à vos yeux il
est nécessaire de passer par une
révision des traités et revenir sur ces
modalités de fonctionnement et de
décision de l'Union
merci Evelyne Renaud garabédian derrière
vous messieurs merci de la présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Pisani
ferry
dans votre rapport intitulé l'action
climatique un enjeu macroéconomique vous
proposez des dix des pistes d'adaptation
de l'économie française à l'objectif de
neutralité carbone en 2050 vous
expliquez que les investigations
supplémentaires
à la teinte des objectifs climatiques
pourraient représenter un ordre de
grandeur de deux points 5 de pipes en
2030 soit 70 milliards d'euros en plus
de ce coût pour les finances publiques
l'État devra aussi aider les acteurs
ménages ou entreprises comme vous le
dites d'ailleurs très justement il y a
beaucoup de mauvaises raisons de
s'endetter mais le climat n'en fait pas
partie
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur les
nécessaires investissements pour la
transition économique qui serait
compatible est-ce qu'ils seront
compatibles dans le cadre budgétaire
européen merci de votre réponse
et Daniel grimillet pour terminer qui a
promis d'être cours
conférencier je crois que ma question
elle est simple vous n'avez pas beaucoup
évoqué l'Europe face à l'Asie face à
l'international donc à en dehors du fait
de dire l'OMC
c'est fini ma question est simple c'est
de savoir pensez-vous que l'Europe
quelque part elle a un peu disparue de
la scène internationale par rapport à
son taux de croissance qui risque d'être
plus faible par rapport aux autres
espaces internationaux
vous organiser
que vous donne quelques minutes pardon
pour à chacun voilà merci
porte sur la
transition climatique j'ai peut-être me
concentrer là-dessus et je voudrais
d'abord
reprendre la question que vous aviez
posé qui est celle de savoir comment les
politiques publiques peuvent réduire le
coût de cette transition et un des
messages dans cette dans cette note dont
je souligne au passage le caractère
préliminaire j'ai pris le risque de
publier tout de suite une note en disant
bien que le travail est loin d'être
terminé mais qui me semblait important
de mettre un certain nombre de choses en
débat à ce stade
donc un des messages de la note c'est
les il y a des coûts qui sont
inévitables d'une certaine manière pour
les raisons que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
mettre du capital de côté parce qu'on
accélère il y a des coûts qui sont
évitables et les coûts qui sont
évitables sont importants alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour limiter
d'abord ça rejoint ce que disait Charles
diplôme avoir une approche économique la
question c'est à dire
c'est entre faire passer un logement
de catégorie
c'est à la catégorie B en termes
d'efficacité énergétique le coût à la
tonne de carbone évité et cette fois
supérieure au coût consistant
correspondant pour faire passer un
logement de la dernière catégorie enfin
une passoire thermique à la même
catégorie B cette fois supérieure donc
ça montre bien que la dispersion des
coûts d'abattement est énorme donc il
faut avoir une approche économique et
donc il faut même si on n'a pas de prix
du carbone il faut qu'on informe toutes
les décisions publiques par une év en
termes de prix du carbone de la tonne de
carbone évité et que ça ça correspond à
une programmation dans le temps la
deuxième chose qui est très importante
c'est
la crédibilité les politiques
climatiques aujourd'hui ne sont pas
crédibles pour des raisons qui tiennent
aux engagements internationaux
nous-mêmes en France nous sommes pas
très crédible parce que par deux fois on
a renoncé la tarification du carbone et
par ailleurs on a raté on est le seul
pays de l'Union européenne qui a raté
ses objectifs de renouvelables pour 2020
et par une marge importante et tenir
l'objectif 2030 sachant que le nucléaire
ne sera pas opérationnel à cette
échéance c'est un défi absolument
considère or si les politiques ne sont
pas crédibles elles ne sont pas non plus
efficaces c'est à dire que on va avoir
des investissements qui on va susciter
si vous voulez pour dire les choses
simplement on va susciter une attitude
d'attente et donc susciter une attitude
d'attente au risque de ne pas être
efficace
sur les autres points donc la question
du poids du long terme
c'est
derrière
le taux d'actualisation il y a eu tout
d'un débat et il y a un accord assez
large pour dire en tout cas parmi les
économistes pour dire qu'il faut
actualiser en donnant du poids en
donnant beaucoup de poids au bien-être
des générations futures
parce que c'était un débat qui a eu lieu
il y a une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années
entre ceux qui disaient on va on doit
utiliser les techniques d'actualisation
usuelle avec le taux d'actualisation
usuel c'est que non il s'agit de
l'avenir
des générations fissures il s'agit de
risque d'irréversibilité et donc il faut
utiliser un taux d'actualisation bas et
moi je suis je pense que le débat a
progressé dans cette direction
sur
la croissance très modeste alors ça donc
sur le
débat il est il est très fort entre
disons Jean-Côme ici qui dit la note
productivité c'est de l'énergie fossile
fondamentalement et donc
si on se passe de l'énergie de fossile
on se passe de la productivité et pour
donner un autre économiste français
notre expert français Philippe Aguillon
qui dit non la réalité c'est que
l'énergie fossile nous a détourné de
techniques qui aujourd'hui sont
potentiellement plus efficaces et donc
les renouvelables ça peut nous amener à
substituer et c'est vrai que ce qui est
très la chute du prix des batteries la
chute du prix du solaire la chute du
prix du des éoliennes est très
impressionnante et ça donne crédit à
cette idée que en fait il y a une
renonce pas nécessairement la croissance
à long terme
est-ce que c'est une opportunité de
reprendre ce qu'on a laissé au marché
moi je ne pense pas parce que je pense
qu'on a doit chercher un équilibre
différent entre
l'initiative privée et les cadrage
public
autrement dit on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas se passer du capitalisme
vert c'est à dire que c'est fondamental
on a besoin de cette innovation on a
besoin de la canaliser on a besoin de
lui donner des indications pour investir
dans le futur mais on a on ne peut pas
faire sans donc je pense que c'est un
équilibre différent
vous avez cité donc ce rapport vous avez
mentionné le chiffre de 2 et demi pour
cent deux et demi pour cent c'est le
montant total des investissements tel
qu'il était évalué par nous d'ailleurs
enfin on a essayé de recenser les
investissements les évaluations qui sont
qui existent c'est le montant total la
question de savoir quelle est la part
publique dans cet investissement c'est
une question à laquelle on n'apporte pas
de réponse aujourd'hui mais on apportera
une réponse lorsque le rapport final
sera publié
mais elle est certainement sensiblement
même très sensiblement inférieur ce
chiffre de 2 et demi pour cent parce que
je pense que c'est probablement quelque
chose de l'ordre
admisive mais c'est sûrement pas de
demi-pension du PIB en revanche c'est
l'effort collectif donc cet effort
collectif il aura des
très rapidement j'imagine
d'abord juste un petit point un peu
technique mais c'est pas les taux de
croissance qui font qui font le poids
et c'est pas les taux de croissance non
plus qui sont un objectif en soi en fait
le défi aujourd'hui celui qui oppose
jean-ovici au reste de la planète on va
dire et pas simplement un fil padian
c'est
c'est en fait d'être capable de
préserver notre niveau de vie donc c'est
pas tellement ce qui nous obsède
aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement le futur
taux de croissance
c'est que nous n'ayons pas des rythmes
de croissance négatif dans les années
qui viennent du fait de l'effondrement
lié par exemple au fait de ne plus
utiliser les fossiles
voilà et la place de l'Europe dans le
monde ne sera pas dépendantes de son
taux de croissance mais sera dépendant
de son niveau de richesse c'est pour
parler très prosaïquement comme on le
faisait au moment de la deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est le nombre de divisions
que vous avez et pas l'augmentation de
ces divisions au cours des 10 dernières
années qui qui est déterminant voilà
donc de ce point de vue là
le l'enjeu il existe mais et on peut
voir dans l'histoire des périodes de
baisse du niveau de vie par exemple à la
chute de l'Empire romain il y a eu une
baisse du niveau de vie en Europe donc
c'est des choses qui peuvent se produire
et c'est ce à quoi aujourd'hui on fait
on fait on fait face par ailleurs dans
le poids qu'on doit donner au futur
ceci se double
de ce qu'on doit absolument éviter les
conséquences d'un changement climatique
au-delà de 1,5 degrés
ou plus de degrés si on est moins
exigeant parce que c'est ces
conséquences du changement climatique
qui auront un coût bien supérieur à tout
ce qu'on peut investir aujourd'hui pour
empêcher ce changement climatique
sachant que ça pose évidemment le
problème de savoir que on doit pas être
les seuls à faire ces investissements
pour
atténuer le changement climatique mais
qu'il faut qu'il soit fait de partout
parce que sinon on peut avoir à la fois
le coût de l'atténuation et le coût du
changement donc tout ça sont des sont
des éléments à prendre en compte mais
qui qui pose le cadre et je pense que
quand on commence à utiliser le mot de
croissance il faut faire attention parce
que souvent en fait on se trompe un
petit peu de débat de ce point de vue là
sur la stratégie du choc comme moyen de
faire avancer les choses je pense que le
plan de Vladimir Poutine c'était de
faire un choc pour faire effondrer
l'Union européenne donc les chocs ont
parfois des vertus mais les chocs sont
aussi ceux qui peuvent provoquer des
effondrements donc là aussi c'est un
équilibre subtil et fin à trouver entre
l'ampleur des chocs et la capacité à en
faire des opportunités c'est évident que
on peut on peut modifier son unifère
mental et envisager des solutions qui
paraissaient inimaginables quand on est
confronté à de nouveaux événements mais
on peut aussi s'effondrer on a quelques
exemples dans l'histoire notamment en
France d'ailleurs d'effondrement
possible très très rapidement face à des
chocs trop violents pour être absorbés
de façon de façon
positive sur le gaz européen il y a
évidemment un point commun avec ce qui a
été fait au moment du au moment du covid
sur les médicaments mais je dirais pas
que c'est la mise en place d'un état de
droit ou de règles en fait c'est
l'acceptation de sa puissance c'est la
possibilité pour un commissaire européen
d'appeler un fabricant de vaccins en lui
disant nous avons commandé 300 millions
de doses nous aurons ces 300 millions de
doses et si vous ne respectez pas votre
parole Vous vous opposez vous vous
exposez à des rétorsions inimaginables
ça c'est l'exercice d'une puissance elle
est faite discrètement par un coup de
téléphone ou par quelques sms mais elle
est extrêmement importante et efficace
cette puissance l'Europe là elle doit la
faire jouer ensuite c'est difficile d'en
faire un une théorisation a priori en
définissant comment on va faire et
comment ça va se passer dans l'exercice
de cette puissance il faut une partie de
discrétion et pas simplement de
discrétionnaire
une partie des réponses que je voulais
donner ont été données juste sur la
dernière chose les médicaments et le gaz
il faut quand même reconnaître que le
médicament ça a pas été un succès
extraordinaire finalement les pays
européens ont été en général en retard
sur les non-pays européens peut-être
parce que la Commission n'avait aucune
expérience peut-être parce qu'il s'est
appris du temps mais il y a eu aussi des
dissensions donc c'est pas
nécessairement un exemple favorable sans
aborder la question du gaz qui est un
peu tard je voulais je voulais peut-être
dire un mot sur notre
l'intervenant historien qui qui
regardait la longue période vous avez
absolument raison l'humanité a
relativement peu progressé jusqu'à la
révolution industrielle et depuis le
monde a complètement changé il n'a
jamais changé aussi rapidement que
durant cette période et effectivement la
croissance a été importante mais dans la
question qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour
le pour contre changements climatique
bien entendu il est pas question de nous
passer des énergies il est question de
développer des sources alternatives
d'énergie et comme l'a fait remarquer
Jean des progrès très rapides ont eu
lieu et d'autres auront encore lieu et
la distinction entre les deux
économistes chez nous on parle plutôt
des pessimistes des optimistes des
capacités d'innovation incroyables de
l'humanité quand elle en a les moyens et
personnellement je suis pas inquiet on
trouvera des solutions mais
ça prend du temps et il y a quelque
chose de dangereux dans le débat sur le
climat qui est cette notion d'urgence
oui il faut prendre des décisions
structurelles fondamentale de manière
urgente pas faire comme sur les 30
dernières années mais pas nécessairement
de vouloir que tous les résultats soient
atteints l'année prochaine ou dans les
cinq ans ou d'ici 2030 l'objectif de 1
degré et demi à 2050 c'est probablement
on vous entend plus
vous ne vous entend plus monsieur le
président
[Musique]
entre vous entends plus
merci
voilà vous en plus bon
bon malheureusement voilà on va pas il
va pas pouvoir entendre que nos
remerciements merci beaucoup monsieur
Timbaud merci beaucoup monsieur Pisani
Ferri merci beaucoup de cet éclairage un
peu trop rapide mais merci infiniment et
je suis sûr qu'on va revenir vers vous
parce que moi j'ai entendu deux trois
sujets qui m'ont voilà qui m'ont parlé
au creux de l'oreille donc on reviendra
vers vous si vous le permettez on lira
avec attention bien sûr les travaux qui
sont les vôtres pour nous donner des
orientations parce qu'en ce moment
légifère beaucoup très très vite et on a
l'impression trop et on les GIF faire
dans l'urgence et les chiffres pour les
20 30 40 prochaines années quelques
temps on aimerait bien se poser cinq
minutes sur la branche pour regarder le
paysage voilà merci beaucoup